hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
castle of devastating diseases okay so
I'm back in the place where I was before
with all my patients still here and
alive considering what I did to him
wow what did I do
I died from what what killed me what
happened ah what the hell happened I've
never died who never died from the red
goop before what the hell okay anyway
that was shocking
alright so it sounds like it's raining
outside
we got something with chains walking
through the halls just banging their
chains on the walls trying to haunt me
ain't gonna happen okay did that work I
was looking over here when that happened
I thought it was coming from this room
oh it's just a painting being knocked
off the wall okay so there was this room
this way section two that I don't think
I've been in our before and let me check
with the front desk but I'm guessing
that the front door is gonna be gobbed
up with goo be goo hello any goo be you
in here good we good how you doing how
you doing guys doing good you doing good
good I okay I'm just gonna walk over
here now see my patient seemed to be
neat whoo you guys I forgot about you
hello hello did you miss me did you miss
doctor dammit God dang it
gosh darn it that hurts real bad why
they pumped up the damage way too high
on that okay so I can't go that way I
can barely see through the goop in front
of my eyes alright let's go to section
two all right yay okay so awaiting me in
this parrot of the castle in this parrot
of the castle and guessing there's got
to be more devastating disease disaster
victims
of some sort loading there we go
okay so my brain is still oozing with
pus so let's just fix it up a bit okay
yeah that's so much better
let me tell you okay so you know a lot
of these areas have reminded me of areas
from amnesia so I'm wondering like
originally amnesia I'm wondering I'm
wondering if maybe hi how you doing man
these lighting these lights don't do
very much I'm trying to save oil cuz I
only got just a little bit left and I
know it's dark I know it's dark I can't
really help it I'm trying to help it but
I can't
let's see anything under the barrels of
New Moon no no okay nothing anything
behind the potatoes no no is enough
potatoes to feed my family for 20 years
our glorious potato day okay ah nothing
what was the point of call okay not that
will grab the doodad grab the duty
donkey where's right here come on man it
can't be that hard
that's what she said whatever all right
let's go up the stairs damn it I'm
wasting oil again wasting way too much
oil hi
what are you stupid mannequins doing
here you're just kind of hanging out and
I don't like it who chest chest gimme
gimme gimme gimme gotta goo yeah that's
not what I really wanted but I'll take
it
I got a bunch of tinderboxes from those
chests over there so I've got plenty I'm
trying to use them up hello sandy okay
you guys need to keep in mind I've got
the volume turned way high in my
headphones so every little tiny bit in
any bitty noise gets amplified him
bajillion times through my heads heads
through my hands you know you know hobby
okay
it's dark dank it's dirty I'm actually
running out of torches which is a good
thing hey that almost looks cheerful
except for those weird blood poop stains
on the wall unless somebody had
dysentery in here okay get out here got
a note to read but first I got to check
all these hello mister cockroach how you
doing yeah run away tinderbox key huh I
have noticed the calamine effects with
healthy people too but I was in the room
wearing him some calamine from
ventilation just few minutes ago my
consciousness started to put down that I
saw many hallucinations I suggest you to
avoid those rooms dr. Morgan okay
whatever you say bro
dr. bro okay bro science ok nothing else
here for me don't know why I use the
lantern on the way out after I lit all
of those torches I am such an idiot
ok so is this the kind of room that's
gonna be bad for my health is my
consciousness slowly draining out of my
face am I going to die very soon
all these questions and more can be
yours for only 1995 hi how you doing
doing good you're doing good do you'll
need bucket on head ok I gently placed
bucket over your head now you'd better
ok - shut up
stop complaining shut up God some people
anything by dirt no ok I'm trying to
find all the secrets but there's nothing
just a whole lot of nothing hello hello
no I'm not gonna waste any tinderboxes
lighting those when there's nothing in
the room and it's dark down here
that's good I know oh hi you're naked we
- ok enough of that
um nope nothing just an arm is this
yours is just your third let let me just
censor that right there oh no it's worse
oh it's so much worse jiggly jiggly okay
alright enough of that Jesus stop it
what's with your imagination everyone
okay let's not hide in the penis room
let's just hide in this room light it up
say mantra to ourselves as we listen to
the horrible horrible horrible music the
horrible very loud in my ears music gay
you don't see thing I'm not here don't
find the guy who's making a go over to
him he wants to see you ha ha ha and I'm
gonna make my escape while your
distorted give me ya bang on that room
oh yeah I'm over there ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha oh look the bar
came off of this door I wonder why oh
hey that goat squeal mmm nothin
wait what's the point of this is this
just a room wait is that that is that a
no that is that okay is that about the
room that he came out of clean away
what's up whoo yeah just what I need
wait a minute I got a key where does
that go - I totally forgot that I had
that key why is it bright daylight but
it's so dark that don't make no set
hang on wait a minute can I get this
gives me I need this I need this I need
this gently up no wrong hang on
got it just work with me buddy okay
all right no wrong no I can get up here
yeah I did it don't know how but I did
it all right what do i do up here what's
the point of up here
what's wait was I not supposed to come
up here did I make a master
okay I done goofed I done goofed and now
that hurt also where it was always over
here maybe this is the thing no wrong I
don't remember there being a locked door
anywhere
alright never let me a locked door mmm
mantris ding where oh where was their oh
oh oh oh section one main hall wait a
minute waiver six and one wait a minute
hold on whoa I'm going the wrong way
here I need to go back cuz this is where
I wait what no it's different no this is
the way where am I now
what what where am I now
I'm so lost hello are you the storage no
where the hell am I can I get out
yeah what did I do
I don't know but I'm so confused where
does this go
blabber yeah I don't know what's going
on I need to go back and find the damn
storage key cuz it says storage in
Section two so I need to find it in here
or I'll have to go back eventually I
think or maybe it's a secret maybe I
don't know maybe I'm going crazy
maybe I need to go back to the room with
the guy with the penis no no there's uh
Quebec there
okay so as the door I came in from what
are you are you a locked door no you're
not you're a different door how are
there so many doors that I didn't see I
swear
everything's changing its changing on me
why this is illogical that's illogical
come hello jump scare jump scare no jump
scare hidey-hole give me give me give me
give me
what is it what what oh I thought you
were all nevermind pop nope yeah good
yeah no nothing
whoa man it is really a nice touch to
have red herrings all over the place you
know empty rooms that don't really have
a purpose that I just go into and just
kind of you know explore and not see it
so it's so cool at this custom stories
actually well oh ha ha ha
yeah got it found it good whoa what the
hell we have received whinings about
storage ventilation from little babies
we checked it and it appears quite much
blocked air comes to storage with huge
delay it has prepared destined possible
okay whatever you say
okay I got a note journal note we know
momento find an item to break that door
fast what why what happened or what do
you mean what door what door what dude
look after the railroad hablar what else
what is what is do what is do happen I'm
so confused
Oh why about I Oh know what door what
door let me throw box on this door oh
yeah yeah open oh no oh no oh what am I
did
what am I done how was I gonna know is
there a crowbar in here uh-huh go
Galloway get up
friggin far away let me take another
look open up give me yeah yeah yeah yeah
I don't know what's happening in this
room but whatever I'm getting out of
here up Hey look there we go all right
I'm out here gosh screw you buddy
huh what was the point of going in there
what was a porter going in there what
was the point
haha there must have been something else
in there value right right there
couldn't have just been no point right
right am I am i right there's huge
stacks of boxes let me turn this off and
just go buy my night vision mode it must
have been that couldn't have been the
only thing in here that was so useless
to me I got one bottle of oil oh here we
go maybe there's a little chest strewn
all over the place with nothing in them
ah alright whatever guys oh these were
the red herring chests for finding the
crowbar okay okay there must be one in
every subsection in this room okay
excuse me where's the other Cho here it
as can give me some oil oil buddy
no a sanity potion I haven't even gone
slightly insane
yeah I was already a mad doctor so I
don't see what difference this makes all
right close the thing down damn door
those that was always to time ha ha ha
that was pointless yes shy of a [ __ ]
you dirty rat I'm gonna stab you in the
butt
ok the game stuttered for a second there
whatever it does that I've assuming
something is about to happen so nothing
got it okay so we unlock the doohickey
to go over here and there's still locked
door over here now have I been in this
area before that is the question it
doesn't look familiar but then again I
played a lot of amnesia in my time so
everything looks a little familiar my
way I think I'm just about out of time
for this part here so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
No
no yes No ah [ __ ] out
oh that would be really there is that is
a joke how's it to jump buzzer I got the
bar the key I'm getting out of here know
what that was all about but I'm not
sticking around to find out